hello and welcome to another episode of
me trying to build this intimate Allison
with a spooky steampunk Alpine kind of
theme as far as I can actually do that
as of recording this it's the first of
January so I hope you've all had a great
time with christmas and happy new year
of course and sorry excuse me if I do
sound a bit sleepy today because of
course I didn't really go to bed at my
regular about time yesterday and waking
up wasn't all that great either but it's
time to pick up roller coaster three
again because I haven't done that in
quite a while and this is kind of an old
recording but anyway I should probably
talk about what I'm doing so I figured
that I would go ahead and just build
stuff in this area basically I wanted to
fill this up with as much stuff that as
I could so I decided to just go crazy
and just let my imagination do whatever
it wanted to do and first thing I
decided to do is to just add a little
building over there because i am afraid
of the emptiness and i just wanted
something everywhere i also decided but
i'm going to show that later on that to
build three large towers all kind of
still inspired by that Professor Layton
kind of thing where you get the kind of
cooked spooky buildings but of course I
do want to keep in the steampunk and
Alpine influences from the rest of the
park so yeah that's basically what's
going to happen today and I decided to
add these vines because I just saw this
sat and I was like damn I haven't used
this sat in years I remember that when
it was like 2010 suit 2010 or 2011 when
everybody was using this and placing it
on support but I haven't seen you too
often lately especially because there
are newer vine sets but I just decided
to see if I could do something with this
sat and it actually turned out to be
pretty useful so yeah I think it looks
pretty cool so I'm just going to go with
that and this was basically me trying to
build those vines everywhere because I I
figured that I could go for a kind of
abandoned look because I have no idea
what such a weird spooky manor kind of
whatever this building even is because
I've no clue this is honestly it's just
about the aesthetics over here it's not
too serious it's not too realistic I
just decided to let myself go with stuff
it's kind of like dude
in roller coaster tycoon 3 whereas
you're not really going for a realistic
theme but more for the details and just
things in general and yeah it's just
it's just about the looks how whatever
you can come up with at the spot and
that's also how doodling works so I
think I do kind of see a well connection
when it comes to that and I like
doodling so I like doing this in roller
coaster in 3 as well but yeah I'm
drifting off basically I just decided to
build that path over over there I've I
still have no clue what to actually do
with that and I'm still procrastinating
that because i suck at planning things I
don't know if you guys have that as well
but I'm really bad at actually getting a
start as soon as I've started building
something it's not that hard for me but
just to get that start just to get that
basic idea in my head and kind of put
that in roller coaster in three and then
move on to all the details is what's the
hardest thing for me but yeah adding
details is something that I do enjoy and
I think I don't really have too many
difficulties with so I just decided to
add some more details through these
buildings because I just picked up some
new sets well I didn't actually pick
them up I had to get them because of
collaborations and stuff and even though
most of the times when i record videos
for other people or pictures or do
collaborations i'm quite bothered to
actually get all of the sets that they
got me because i needed them of course
to open their park files but then again
it is pretty cool to have some new sets
that I've never used before and
sometimes it really does help and just
scrolling through a new set and looking
at all the pieces is something that I
also enjoy the only problem that I have
with this which is not really a problem
but it's a minor nuisance is the fact
that it doesn't really deliver the best
time lapses and I realized that time
lapsing something like this is very
different from time lapse in a building
which I already have a very clear idea
in my head or doing foliage you're doing
rock work or building coasters building
coasters are probably the best thing to
time lapse or even to not time lapse
it's probably the most exciting things
to watch but this is just the kind of
moments where you need to experience
what it sent our works like and where
you kind of need to mess around with it
and it's more like trial and error and
experimental ism then it really is
something building and something that's
very fit for doing your time-lapse so ya
doing that experimental stuff is kind of
what I'm doing in this episode and the
style however it wasn't so experimental
because it was of course inspired by
another tower that I know but then again
it's something I've never ever done in
roller coaster can three I don't think
I've ever seen it in roller coaster
going through really but I think it
turned out pretty pretty decent yeah um
I don't think it's too unrealistic
because before I had that idea to build
a tower like that and I kind of crooks
our that looks like it's about to
collapse but doesn't really collapse is
the problem that it might look very
unrealistic especially in professor
layton where the tower is nearly
levitating and just looks unnatural I
decided that I would want something like
that and I'm not going for a realistic
park in the sense that and no park would
actually build scenery like this it's
way too expensive even Disney wouldn't
do that but I do want to keep the basic
realism I don't want to negate gravity
or anything like that so just to keep
that basic realism in there is something
that I do need to keep in mind and that
was something that I was worried about
when building that when building that
building but I do think it looks okay I
think it looks realistic enough and yeah
other other than that this is all just
scrolling through sets and looking at
things and just thinking hmm i might add
that and i do realize that I might give
this as a tip also to myself but i just
keep forgetting about this if you do
this if you just scroll through sets and
look at details that you want to add two
buildings don't do what I do and do it
for just a couple of buildings of which
you still want to build more but first
finish all of the buildings that you
want to do in that style and then do all
of the very tiny details if you want to
try that because if you do it earlier on
and you still need to add a couple more
buildings you're gonna forget which sets
you got all of those small pieces from
or it's going to take a very long time
and if you just do the basic shapes of
buildings first and then finish all of
that and then move on to the details
it's actually
a lot more efficient and less annoying
in the long run only I am an idiot and i
just keep forgetting my own tips and
stuff like that so that's why i didn't
do that but don't be me tooth there do
that holy [ __ ] i haven't had enough
sleep today nope so yeah I don't really
know what else I'm going to do with this
area though I've been saying for a very
long time that I would add a kids area
or more flat rides or something around
this but I honestly have no clue how I'm
going to do that and I also have no clue
how I'm going to do the foliage because
I do kind of want to try some spooky ish
foliage but then again if you do that
it's most likely going to be unrealistic
or it's going to have a different season
than the rest of the pike and I don't
really want that because once again this
bike is unrealistic but I do want to
keep basic rules of realism of course so
I'm not going to build multiple seasons
forests elevated here in this park that
wouldn't make too much sense and this is
the part where I get to building the
three towers by the way I suppose I'm
not too sure about them I think I'll let
them stay but if you really don't want
that I don't know I don't have any other
ideas this was kind of the basic idea
that I had and I wanted to go for a
spooky ish skyline I don't think that
makes too much sense or is ever done
before but I just I like skylines and
maybe experimenting with stuff and
building some different things than
usual might seem like a great idea but
of course the only only risk with these
towers is that I had no clue how this is
going to look and I still don't have a
clue and this might end up looking
unrealistic and weird and ugly which I
don't hope and I also don't think but
I'll i guess i'll have to see when the
park is finished but yeah other than
that I think I'll just need to add a
couple of small buildings around this
area just to kind of cover up all of the
emptiness because I'm afraid of the
emptiness and I need to finish the
station because the station has a very
slight idea ish kind of concepts and
some floating roofs but nothing more and
I definitely to get
around to actually finish that and this
is where I mess with the foliage I try
to use the same kinds of sets that I've
used in the rest of the park and mix in
a couple of dead trees and I do feel
like that does make a bit of sense but
I've no clue how to actually make it
more spooky the only thing that I can
think of is actually getting some of the
dead trees and stuff from fishers
enchanted forest but I've no clue how
that is actually going to look because
it's a very magical ish set and it does
have some weird fantasy ish pieces but I
guess I'll see at some point and anyway
this is the end of the episode so thank
you for watching and see you in the next
one in which I'm going to do something I
have no clue actually